i think that he should uh she rather
brad pascal
uh running his campaign what do you
think about that i think i just didn't
get enough sleep last night i had no
intention of uh
mixing them up
joy behar that lady on the view fell
into this problem when when she was
announcing that
caitlyn jenner is running for governor
she referred to him
as him sonny he's got this guy brad
pasquel
running his campaign what do you think
about that i mean that guy
was uh was accused of using uh campaign
funds to enrich himself what that's
who's running his campaign
or her campaign rather i would go along
with that i think that he
should or she rather should take a seat
and let somebody with the credentials
take over a major state like california
so i've never said this before but joy
behar i think is a good example of most
of america
i don't think that joy behar did this
intentionally i don't think this was
a subtle dig you know she kept
correcting herself she said
yeah and i don't think he should i mean
she i'm sorry she
maybe it was a subtle dig at the
transgender thing but i think
more likely joy behar woman of a certain
age remembers bruce jenner the guy's
been famous for a very long time
and he's the most famous athlete in the
world he's the first woman to win the
decathlon
right and we've all known him as he
since he was on the wheaties box
and over the last few years he's
pretending to be she but
for people who remember him it's you
can't do that
it's very difficult to do that so what
does joy behar do
she apologizes so first of all let me
apologize for my pronoun mix-up
i i think i just didn't get enough sleep
last night i had no intention of uh
mixing them up but and i tried to
correct it immediately but
whatever it just came out so i'm sorry
if anybody was upset by that
i can't belie i can believe that she had
to apologize this apology didn't sound
particularly sincere to me she was like
i mixed it up come on give me a break
if you're offended whatever i'm sorry
i have heard conservatives i don't
question how conservative they are but
self-styled conservatives
have referred to the misgendering
of caitlyn jenner misgendering is a
leftist term
that that refers to when you call a man
a man
but if the man thinks he's a woman and
you call him a man that's called
misgendering
now of course the the more precise term
would be gendering
the only people misgendering bruce
jenner are the people who are caitlyn
jenner now
are the ones who were referring to him
as her but even some
self-styled right-wingers are adopting
this language
even some stealth self-styled
right-wingers are saying no really come
on to be polite
we should refer to him as her quite the
opposite actually
quite the opposite it's disrespectful to
refer to him as her no it's not
it's disrespectful to treat him like a
complete lunatic and indulge his
fantasies and say oh yes you really are
a woman
sir lady whatever no the truth is
respectful
it can be harsh sometimes and euphemisms
try to
sugarcoat harsh truths but the truth is
respectful
and lies are very disrespectful you
don't lie to people that
you respect you certainly don't
habitually lie to them as as in the case
of referring to
caitlyn jenner as a as a woman
this this idea very prominent on the
left now
that that lies are compassionate and the
truth is cruel that is
a wicked totally backwards idea
and if conservatives adopt that we're
lost we are totally lost
and there therein lies the real poison
of the gender candidacy
you're already seeing some conservatives
adopt this language you gotta
stop this before it gets too far
regardless of how the california
election turns out
caitlyn jenner is more the norm
in this regime than the average
conservative is
yes oh we think caitlyn jenner is a
sideshow
a reality tv star a famous athlete going
back many decades
who's now making even more of a
spectacle of himself
he is much more the norm he is much more
accepted by the dominant liberal regime
than you deplorable people are you
deplorable
irredeemable bible thumping bitter
clinging
middle americans you are considered
the oddity you are considered the
bizarre
you should be part of the circus caitlyn
jenner no
he's just a man following his true self
because he's trapped inside the wrong
body or whatever
this is the dominant ideology it goes by
the name lgbtq
right now even this this
initialism doesn't make any sense
because the logic for the l and the g
totally undermines the logic for the t
the logic for the l and the g
is i'm born this way i have certain
sexual desires you can't change these
sexual desires it's it's very wrong to
shame people for their desires and so
come on you know let
when boys from a very early age are
attracted to other boys just come on let
them do it right okay i don't totally
understand
that logic the logic of the t
is actually no there's no such thing as
innate sex there's no forget innate
sexual desire there's no such thing as
innate sex
it sex is totally socially constructed
there's really no difference between a
man and a woman
and therefore a man can be a woman
very easily just by saying so that logic
undercuts
the other logic now there is a little
bit of a connection here
in that the gender ideologues took
one of the claims of the t took one of
the claims of the l and the g
and brought it to a radical conclusion
and that claim is that
for the logic for instance of gay
marriage
the claim here is that man plus man
equals man plus woman right that's the
equal sign that these are exactly the
same thing there's no distinction
whatsoever sexual difference has nothing
to do with marriage
so if you just do a little basic math
here
if m plus m equals
m plus w then that means you take out
some of the m's here you're kind of
mixed around
that m equals w it means that men and
women are indistinguishable
by the logic of redefining marriage so
then what the transgender
ideologues do is they take that and they
say okay well if men and women are
indistinguishable then
bruce jenner can become caitlyn jenner
and he can he can now become she and
there's no no
problem here it's it's obviously very
convoluted it's a little bit complex but
this is the state
ideology now hey wait a second don't go
anywhere i've had you know i've had some
people write into me and they say
michael
for some reason i'm not getting
notifications for your show
hey michael for some reason even when i
search for your show the videos aren't
always popping up
yeah i think it's because our overlords
don't
love us necessarily in this big tech
space make sure you
smash that button you like you subscribe
you do everything in your power to get
those notifications you still probably
won't get them but it'll give you a
better chance
of not missing a single video
[Music]
[Music]
you